All right.
By popular demand, I'm going to do a sort
of full review of the Andrew Cuomo covid cover
up claims that are circulating so we can try
to sort of sort out what's truth and what's
lies and what we know about and what we don't
know about and sort of what's relevant to
policy versus what are sort of like the more
a personal scandals in which Andrew Cuomo
is now embroiled.
So let's get right into it.
Earlier in the pandemic, New York Democratic
Governor Andrew Cuomo was seen as sort of
a model governor in responding to the pandemic.
And despite New York being hit very hard,
early, believed to be because of the number
of nonstop flights both to China, sort of
like source one for the virus and Italy and
surrounding parts of Europe, sort of like
source two for the virus in the United States.
Despite that, the idea was that Cuomo handled
the virus as well as was possible, given what
we knew at the time and ramped up testing
relatively quickly, as quickly as feasible,
put in place guidelines did shut downs as
necessary.
And while much of the United States had three
spikes, New York was able to completely suppress
the what was typically spike to for much of
the country in the middle of the summer.
And they had basically the initial spike and
then the false spike, limiting themselves
to two spikes rather than three.
Thanks to Andrew Cuomo, great work.
Now, until more recently, some very serious
allegations of the covering up of deaths have
surfaced.
So let's go through the allegations.
From the emails I've gotten, a lot of people
don't actually understand what is even being
alleged.
Now, I want to be up front that much of much
of this is still disputed and contested.
And just about every report has some detail
that is not at least yet confirmed.
But we're going to do the best we can to pass
through the evidence.
We have the big scandal and the big allegation
is that at Andrew Cuomo, either direction
or indifference nursing home covid deaths
were undercounted by the state, allegedly
to the tune of thousands of nursing home covid
deaths.
And indeed, the New York Health Department
has made public data that added more than
3800 nursing home deaths to their tally after
this story broke.
And the state now acknowledges that they upped
nursing home deaths by about 40 percent.
Now, it's really important to be clear here,
and this is what a lot of people may be missing.
This is not an allegation that New York undercounted
covid deaths nationally, even globally.
We believe that there have been far more covid
deaths than the official numbers because of
people who died, including at home, and were
never tested.
But the allegation is not that the full public
number of New York covid deaths is being artificially
suppressed any more than just were probably
undercounting covid deaths at a global level.
The current New York covid death toll is about
47000 and that has nothing to do with these
allegations.
What's at issue is how many nursing home residents
died.
And our best understanding of the undercount
is that there were thousands of nursing home
residents who became so sick that they went
to a hospital, died in the hospital, and they
were not counted as nursing home deaths.
Now, in a literal sense, they did die at the
hospital.
But we all understand that if you are a nursing
home resident who catches the virus at a nursing
home, you should be counted as a nursing home
death.
From the standpoint of evaluating how well
did Andrew Cuomo protect nursing home residents?
And that's the crux of this.
Even if the total number of deaths is not
being lied about, if you undercount nursing
home deaths, you are making it seem as though
you are much better protecting nursing homes
than you really are.
So this is dishonest and Andrew Cuomo has
to be held accountable.
This has a real impact.
It's not just academic.
It's not just a number of families make decisions
about facilities for loved ones, in part based
on whether they believe their loved ones will
or won't be safe at nursing homes.
If you falsely believe that there are way
fewer nursing home covid deaths than there
really are, you might make a decision about
a loved one based on those deceptive statistics.
So this is very real, very serious, and it
has a real world impact.
Now, what are the defenses?
The defenses are what we heard from Health
Commissioner Howard Zucker from New York,
which is that the state website had always
been clear that deaths it listed for nursing
homes did.
Not include deaths that took place outside
the facility and that the total number of
deaths was never undercounted.
That's the defense from the New York Health
Health Department.
Then there's the second piece of this, which
is the criticism that New York State sent
nursing home residents who were hospitalized
back to nursing homes in cases where they
shouldn't have been sent back.
This one is more nebulous right now.
We're still learning and learning more about
it.
Andrew Cuomo is defending this and saying
that everybody that was sent back was sent
back in adherence to in compliance with federal
guidelines and that they didn't do anything
that was wrong.
Now, on the second issue, I'm not really able
to put together a definitive take on it.
We just need more information about that.
Now, separately, and this is a lot of stuff
happening all at once to Andrew Cuomo separately,
there are allegations of Andrew Cuomo being
basically a bad guy, bullying employees and
treating employees terribly.
I see this as important, but secondary to
the covid scandal.
It's a lot of he said she said I can't possibly
analyze it in any serious way other than to
say all of the allegations should be investigated
and the cards should fall where they may.
I don't care that Andrew Cuomo is a Democrat.
Whatever whatever is uncovered should be what
it is and it should be dealt with.
And then lastly, there are also now new allegations
of inappropriate sexual advances and conduct
by Andrew Cuomo.
Lindsay Boylan, who worked for Cuomo as an
aide, says that on a private jet, Cuomo suggested
playing strip poker, which made her feel uncomfortable.
Boylan says that that happened after she was
promoted to be Cuomo deputy secretary for
economic development and a special adviser
to him.
She said she initially turned the job down
because she didn't want to be near him, ultimately
accepted it.
Boylen also is describing an incident where
they were in his office in New York City on
Third Avenue.
And when she got up to leave and walk out
a door that Andrew Cuomo allegedly stepped
in front of her, kissed her on the lips, and
that she was shocked but just kept walking
out.
Now, this is totally separate and this allegation
has to be taken seriously and fully pursued.
So that's the story.
As I understand it, some of the emails I received
were implying I wasn't going to talk about
this because Cuomo is a Democrat.
First of all, we talked about this last week
for a while on the bonus show.
Secondly, I've said a million times, I don't
care about these politicians beyond.
They're doing things for the people.
I don't care if they're Democrats or Republicans.
I never defended, you know, Anthony Weiner.
I don't defy politicians.
They all have good and bad.
And why wouldn't I talk about Andrew Cuomo,
investigate every single thing?
If the people of New York want him to resign,
he should consider resignation.
If there are criminal wrongdoings, then investigate
and prosecute.
We don't ignore stories because it's a Democrat
on this show.
That is the full story.
As far as I understand.
It's a really sort of like four stories.
The undercount of nursing home deaths, sending
patients from hospitals back to nursing homes,
the bullying of employees and the alleged
sexual harassment of Lindsay Boyland.
Those are the four stories.
As I understand them.
They are separate stories.
We could sort of group them as the two covid
stories and the two bullying and harassment
stories.
And we'll just have to follow all of them
and see where the cards fall.